série on continue avec une info qui
concerne le fils d'alain delon anthony
delon il était sur rtl hier pour parler
des violences dont il aurait été victime
de la part de son père est violent ce
qu'il raconte dans son livre
autobiographique c'est un truc de fou
saulnier coups de fouet étranglement
assiette qui volent par la fenêtre c'est
très chaud ou vous avez un petit récap
de tout ça et on en parle juste après
bernard montiel qui doit connaître le
dossier bah sinon il peut rentrer chez
lui
[Musique]
anthony delon s'était déjà confié à
plusieurs reprises sur son enfance
difficile et l'attitude violente de son
père alain delon m'enfermer dans une
cage des chiens pour m'endurcir
aujourd'hui à l'occasion de la sortie de
son livre autobiographique entre chien
et loup anthony delon revient plus en
détail sur ces sévices infligés par son
père notamment lors d'un dîner pris
d'une rage subite il attrapa mon
assiette et l'a projetée par la fenêtre
il raconte que son père le battait à
plusieurs reprises et lui aurait même
dit même mes chiens je ne fera pas avec
ceux fouet des anecdotes qui font froid
dans le dos pourtant anthony delon
confie ne pas vouloir régler ses comptes
avec celui qui s'est comporté en
bourreau pendant plusieurs années
j'aurais pu en déduire que cet homme mon
père ne m'aimait pas mais j'avais
compris qu'il m'avait désirer comme rien
d'autre monde si la violence a laissé
des traces dans leur relation il faut
croire que chez des deux longs l'amour
triomphera toujours
oui celle vers des bons alors on va pas
se le cacher là ils le sortent dans un
livre on le savait quand même même si le
père a toujours démenti les actes de
violence ça a été une éducation très dur
et c'est vrai qu'il y avait des coups il
y avait une sorte de désamour et là
c'est bizarre parce qu'il dit en même
temps que c'est pas pour régler des
comptes mais ça va agrandir le fossé qui
est toujours resté béant entre à cause
de ça notamment une enfance très
difficile avec beaucoup de violence
c'est vrai c'est vrai il faut quand même
reconnaître qu anthony a été élevé par
sa mère il n'est pas que alain ce n'est
pas beaucoup occupé c'est vrai il lui a
toujours reproché mam à tel point qu'à
une époque anthony avait fait quelques
bêtises d'ailleurs j'ai pas si vous vous
rappelez bon il a vu quelques sociale et
de la justice mais évidemment que si oui
ou non mais tout est oublié donc si vous
voulez le rapport ont toujours est a
toujours été conflictuelle à une époque
il avait pris le nom à des qui comme son
nom anthony delon alain lui avait refusé
et il est vrai que l'un est colérique
mais le colérique et qui peut gueuler
s'emporter très vite moi je n'ai vu
souvent s'emporter contre des personnes
or soit canton son fils est regrettable
bâton contre qui que ce soit c'est
regrettable mais alain et colérique donc
voilà maintenant ça il avait déjà dit à
quelques années maintenant il ressort
dans un livre ça m'étonne quand même
parce que les rapports entre ce temps
sont bons non d'accord et sap a toujours
été le cas moi je me souviens il
mireille darc était comme une des plus
proches café et mireille c'est vraiment
occupé d'anthony qu'anthony revenu vivre
à paris puisque à l'époque il vivait à
los angeles avec sa mère et et c'est
vrai que le rapport a toujours été
difficile tiers qu'il a toujours voulu
être très aimé par son père et qui s'est
jamais sentie très aimé par son père
donc je comprends sa douleur c'est un
garçon très bien qu a beaucoup souffert
donc maintenant qu'il ose dire ça je
trouve ça énorme mais présent qui son
père et au conte comme il à le remettre
dans un livre ou pas du tout sincèrement
je ne pense pas non je ne pense pas
parce qu'ils sont libres était sous
embargo la pop a ha oui oui sûrement je
pense pas parce que valérie bègue non
mais oui le livre était sous embargo
alors embargo pour les téléspectateurs
ça veut dire que personne y compris
journalistes n'avaient pas accès aux
livres est donc bon bah c'est vraiment
le moment où le livre sort que les
journalistes et le grand public a accès
aux informations en même temps c'est ça
un an par alain delon dépôt courant
parce qu'il a dit anthony l'a dit serein
sur rtl alors vers son interview il a
dit oui c'est bien d'avoir quelqu'un
dans un cadre tard
journaliste lui pose la question est
comment a réagi votre papa est dit pour
l'instant il n'a pas encore réagi quoi
je pense qu'il ne sait pas quand voilà
c'est ça et c'est vrai que c'est
étonnant parce qu'on les a vus beaucoup
ensemble reçu un oui et on pensait
qu'ils s'étaient réunis on sait que ça
allait mieux et je pensais que ça allait
mer mais peut-être qu'il a eu envie de
le dire aussi ça fait du bien de dire
les choses et qu au bout d un moment
voilà peut-être faire du mal aux tirs
mais en tout cas sur ce il le sait il va
pas être content du tout du tout parce
que c'est un homme extrêmement discret
relais on sait très bien qu'il est
discret qu'il a toujours caché sa vie de
toute façon et là là dessus que son fils
la taxe comme ça boit ça m'étonne pas ce
que ça allait mieux entre eux surtout en
cette période un peu difficile où allah
n'est pas très en forme donc voilà ça
m'étonne c'est vous ça vous étonne pas
ce que ça allait me entre eux we fall et
je le répète de nouveau c'est ça
qu'est ce qui est important
[Musique]
ça vous étonne parce que ça nous faisait
honte parce que ça allait mieux entre
eux bah oui quand ça va bien avec
quelqu'un on oublie un peu la peur de
quoi maintenant
maintenant j'ai peur de quoi moi murray
par rapport à la relation mais qu'ils
sachent et là le père masashi c'est
évidemment oui je pense
oui ça m'étonne si ça
[Rires]
m'étonne pas ce que ça allait mieux
entre eux ah oui
c'est étonnant parce que voilà et c'est
bon
mais c'est ça son problème
moi j'ai une grande passion pour alain
delon voilà je vous le dis d'accord pas
très bien ça nous fait une belle jambe
et non mais non quand même dire qu'il y
avait des enfants non mais toujours ça
non il faut quand même y envoyer un sms
il devint un truc comme une enfant tue
quand même dire que dans le livre il dit
cette information parce qu'il avait
besoin de la dire mais en même temps il
c1 en même temps parce qu'en est il des
douanes aussi son père leur disant j'ai
toujours cru qu'il ne m'aimait pas or
j'ai appris que j'étais la prunelle de
ses yeux et que il m'avait désirer comme
comme il n'avait jamais désiré personne
d'autre quoi donc voilà il sait aussi un
cri d'amour mais ça des douanes la
violence du coup si j y aura quelque
chose à vous dire tout à l'heure parce
que je faisais quand ils vous regardent
comme ça on y va ça va pas ça va pas le
faire